L
DIG VERY DEEPLY INTO THE BIDEN
CRIME FAMILY AND THE LAPTOP
AND TWITTER AND THE ISSUES
ASSOCIATED BUT BEFORE WE GET
THERE YOU HAVE HEARD IT SAID
AND IT IS CORRECT THE NATION'S
TERRIBLY DIVIDED.
BUT WHAT YOU HAVEN'T HEARD OF
ANYTHING THE SUPERFICIAL WIRE
WE DIVIDED THE WAY THE NATION
IS SO THOROUGHLY DIVIDED WITH
THOSE WHO BELIEVE THE FOUNDING
PRINCIPLES OF OUR COUNTRY AND
WITH THE BILL OF RIGHTS AND
THE ISSUES RELATED AND THOSE
WHO WANT TO CHANGE THE COUNTRY
THE DISMANTLING OF AMERICA
THERE ARE AMERICANS ALIVE AT
THIS MOMENT WHO MAY EXPERIENCE
A NATIONAL EQUIVALENT OF A
PERFECT STORM EITHER
DOMESTICALLY AND
INTERNATIONALLY OR BOTH TO
HAVE WHAT IS A PERFECT STORM
FORCES MUST COME TOGETHER AT
THE SAME TIME THOSE DANGEROUS
FORCES HAVE BEEN BUILDING IN
THE UNITED STATES FOR HALF A
CENTURY.
BY 2010 INCREASING NUMBERS OF
AMERICANS ARE BEGINNING TO
EXPRESS FEARS THEY WERE LOSING
THE COUNTRY THINKER OF THEM.
THAT THEY HOPED AND ASSUMED
THEY WOULD BE PASSING ON TO
THEIR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN.
NO ONE HAS BEEN ENOUGH TO
CREATE A PERFECT STORM FOR A
GREAT NATION THAT HAS
WEATHERED MORE THAN STORMS AND
TWO CENTURIES OF EXISTENCE BUT
THE ROMAN EMPIRE LASTED MANY
TIMES LONGER AND WEATHERED
MANY STORMS YET ULTIMATELY
COLLAPSED COMPLETELY IS
ESTIMATED 1000 YEARS PASSED
BEFORE THE STANDARD OF LIVING
ROSE THE NEW YORK TO THE LEVEL
IT ACHIEVED IN ROMAN TIMES THE
COLLAPSE OF THE CIVILIZATION
IS NOT JUST THE REPLACEMENT OF
RULERS OR INSTITUTIONS OR NEW
INSTITUTIONS IT IS A WHOLE WAY
OF LIFE AND PAINFUL AND
PATHETIC ATTEMPTS TO REBUILD
THE RUINS THE PAINFUL
SURPRISES SOMETHING PEOPLE
BASE THEIR HOPES ON OBAMA'S
WORDS RATHER THAN THE RECORD
OF HIS DEEDS.
THAT MEANS EVEN IF WE MANAGE
TO SURVIVE HIS RATE RECKLESS
ECONOMIC POLICIES AT HOME AND
POTENTIALLY FATAL
FOREIGN-POLICY ACTION AND
INACTION THE GULLIBILITY OF
THOSE VOTERS WHO PUT HIM IN
THE WHITE HOUSE WILL STILL BE
THERE.
TO BE EXPLOITED BY THE MASTER
WHO IS NEXT AND LEAD US INTO
ANOTHER VORTEX OF DANGER FROM
WHICH THERE IS NO GUARANTEE WE
WILL EMERGE AS A FREE PEOPLE
OR A VIABLE SOCIETY.
OUR CONCERN IS NOT WITH ONE
MAN BUT WITH A COUNTRY OF
HISTORY IS SHOWN REPEATEDLY
ONE MAN IN A KEY POSITION CAN
BRING DOWN THE WHOLE COUNTRY
IN RUINS.
THE HISTORY AS TO THE
CONFLUENCE OF FORCES TO REDUCE
A PERFECT STORM.
WHEN WE LOOK BACK AT A DECADES
LONG EROSION AND DISTORTION OF
OUR LEGAL AND POLITICAL SYSTEM
WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT
THE KINDS OF DANGERS WE FACE
NOW THAT WERE ALWAYS INHERENT
THOMAS SOUL DISMANTLING
AMERICAN WHAT ARE WE UP
AGAINST WHY IS IT THE COUNTRY
IS SO THOROUGHLY DIVIDED WHAT
TURNS AMERICA AGAINST AMERICA
ARE ONE THIRD WITH
CONTRIBUTIONS TO HUMANITY?
ONE OF THE GREAT ECONOMIC
PHILOSOPHERS OF THE LAST
CENTURY WROTE A BOOK CALLED
MARXISM EN MASSE FROM DILUTION
TO DESTRUCTION WHAT HE SAID
MORE ARTICULATELY THAT I IS
THAT THE PHILOSOPHY OF TODAY
IS THAT OF KARL MARX THE MOST
POWERFUL PERSONALITY OF OUR
AGE KARL MARX IN THE IDEA
WHICH HE DID NOT INVENT ARE
PUT INTO A WIDELY ACCEPTED
IDEA EVEN THOSE WHO
EMPHATICALLY DECLARE THEIR
ANTI-COMMUNIST AND MARXIST
MANY PEOPLE ARE PHILOSOPHICAL
MARXIST ALTHOUGH THEY USE
DIFFERENT NAMES FOR THOSE
PHILOSOPHICAL IDEAS AND HE IS
RIGHT IT TRULY DOMINATES THE
INTERPRETATION OF CURRENT
EVENTS AND HISTORY IN POPULAR
BOOKS AS WELL AS AND
PHILOSOPHICAL WRITINGS AND
NOVELS AND PLAYS OR BY A LARGE
MARXIST.
IT IS SOMETHING I HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO EXPLAIN MYSELF AND
WROTE AN ENTIRE BOOK ON.
MARXISM, PROGRESSIVISM THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WHEN YOU LISTEN TO SCHUMER AND
POLICY AND AOC AND SANDERS DO
THEY SOUND LIKE PEOPLE WHO ARE
TALKING IN WAYS THAT WE
EMBRACE THE FOUNDING OF THE
NATION OF LIBERTY AND PROPERTY
RIGHTS AND INDIVIDUALISM AND
UNALIENABLE RIGHTS OR IS IT
CLASS WARFARE THE RICH VERSUS
THE POOR?
TODAY TALK ABOUT THE
INEQUITIES THESE ARE MARXIST
IDEOLOGIES WILL GIVE YOU A
PERFECT EXAMPLE OF A NICE SEE
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
CLASSROOMS AND THE DESTRUCTION
OF REAL EDUCATION WE SEE THE
EFFORT TO SAY THAT PARENTS
HAVE NO SAY IN EDUCATION AND
BUREAUCRATS THE UNION MEMBERS
HAVE AS MUCH RIGHT TO CONTROL
YOUR CHILDREN AND THEIR MINDS
AS PARENTS DO THEY DON'T HAVE
ANY SAY THIS IS FROM THE
COMMUNIST MANIFESTO IT IS
MISCONCEPTION THAT HAS YOU
TRANSFORM INTO THE INTERNAL
LAWS OF NATURE AS TO ATTACK
THE DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE SPECIFICALLY AND
THE SOCIAL FORM SPRINGING FROM
YOUR PRESENT MODE OF
PRODUCTION AND PROPERTY
HISTORICAL RELATIONS THAT RISE
AND DISAPPEAR WITH PRODUCTION
AND MISCONCEPTION YOU SHARE
WITH EVERY RULING CLASS THAT
HAS PROCEEDED YOU WHAT YOU SEE
CLEARLY IN THE CASE OF ANCIENT
PROPERTY WOULD MET IN THE CASE
OF FUTILE PROPERTY YOU ARE
PERMITTED TO ADMIT FROM YOUR
OWN FORM OF PROPERTY TO DRAW
THE WEALTHIER, THE PROLETARIAT
WHAT WE WOULD CALL THAT
MIDDLE-CLASS EVEN THOUGH MARX
NEVER DESCRIBES WHAT THE
MIDDLE CLASS IS THAT USES IT
ALL THE TIME JUST AS DEMOCRATS
DO AND BIDEN DOES WHAT IS HE
TALKING ABOUT?
HE IS TALKING ABOUT PROPERTY
OF YOUR CHILDREN BECAUSE
EVERYTHING IS ABOUT A
DIALECTIC SYSTEM THE PROPERTY
OF YOUR CHILDREN AND SAYS
ABOLITION OF THE FAMILY!
EVEN THAT INFAMOUS PROPOSAL OF
THE COMMUNIST ON WHAT
FOUNDATION IS IT BASED?
ON CAPITAL AND PRIVATE GAIN
AND IS COMPLETELY DEVELOPED
THE FAMILY EXIST ONLY AMONG
THE WEALTHY AND THE
BOURGEOISIE BUT FINDS ITS
COMPLEMENT AMONG THE
PROLETARIANS IN PUBLIC
PROSTITUTION AMONG THE PEOPLE
THE FAMILY IS NOT STRONG OR
VIBRANT JUST THE WEALTHY
RULING PEOPLE THE EXECUTIVES
THEY KEEP PUSHING THIS IDEA OF
A NUCLEAR FAMILY THE BOURGEOIS
FAMILY WILL VANISH AS A MATTER
OF COURSE BOTH WILL VANISH
WITH THE VANISHING OF CAPITAL
DO YOU CHARGE US WITH WANTING
TO STOP THE EXPLOITATION OF
CHILDREN WITH THEIR PARENTS?
YOU SEE THE POINT TO THIS
CRIME WE PLEAD GUILTY YOU'LL
SAY WE DESTROYED FROM
EDUCATION AND SOCIAL EDUCATION
AND YOUR EDUCATION IS ALSO NOT
DETERMINE THE SOCIAL
CONDITIONS BY WHICH YOU
EDUCATE ME IN THE DIRECTION BY
THE NEEDS OF SCHOOLS?
THE COMMUNIST HAVE NOT
INVENTED SOCIETY AND EDUCATION
BUT THEY SEEK TO ALTER THAT
AND TO RESCUE FROM THE
INFLUENCE OF THE RULING CLASS.
THEY WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE CLASSROOMS TODAY?
UNDERSTAND MARXISM.
UNDERSTAND WHAT HAS BEEN SAID
THIS IS AN INTENT TO DESTROY
THE NUCLEAR FAMILY BECAUSE IN
ORDER TO INDOCTRINATE YOUR
CHILDREN AS ACTORS FOR THE
STATE YOU HAVE TO DESTROY THE
FAMILY.
THE GREATEST OBSTACLES TO
ADVANCING THIS SO-CALLED NERVE
ON OR PARADISE OR UTOPIA IS
THE FAMILY AND FAITH.
NOW EVEN IN OVERWHELMING
NUMBER OF SENATORS WHO VOTED
FOR WHAT THEY CALL THE RESPECT
OF MARRIAGE ACT THAT HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH MARRIAGE IT
SHOULD BE CALLED THE WAR UPON
RELIGION ACT BECAUSE THE GOAL
OF THE LAW AS DEMONSTRATED BY
MIKE LEE'S AMENDMENT IS TO
PREVENT RELIGIOUS INSTITUTIONS
ORTHODOX INSTITUTIONS
CHRISTIAN INSTITUTIONS, MUSLIM
INSTITUTIONS FROM TEACHING
THEIR FAITH IN VARIOUS FORMATS
HOSPITALS, SCHOOLS, THINK
TANKS AND TO CREATE FEDERAL
CRIMES OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CAN POSE ITS WELL
THE WAR ON THE FAMILY IS
TAKING PLACE EVERY SINGLE DAY
WHEN YOU TURN ON TV AND WATCH
THE COMMERCIALS BUT THIS IS
JUST ONE LITTLE PIECE THE WAR
ON AMERICAN HISTORY HISTORY
THAT BROUGHT US THE FREEST
NATION ON THE FACE OF THE
EARTH OVER TIME AMERICANS
FOUGHT A CIVIL WAR WITH OVER
700,000 CASUALTIES TO END
SLAVERY KEEP THE UNION NO
COUNTRY HAS FOUGHT A WAR OVER
SLAVERY LIKE THAT.
WE DID AND ALL THE EFFORTS
ECONOMIC AND LEGAL AND
OTHERWISE TO MAKE AMENDS AS IF
THEY NEVER TOOK PLACE WE ARE
GREAT NATION THAT REPRESENTS
THE UNALIENABLE RIGHTS OF THE
INDIVIDUAL COMING FROM GOD BUT
THERE IS A NATURAL LOT OF GOOD
AND EVIL AT ALL OF OUR RIGHTS
IN THE LAW TO COME FROM THE
PRESENT-DAY POLITICIANS AND
THEIR SUPPOSED WISDOM THIS IS
A BIG DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
MARXIST IDEOLOGY AND BUILT ON
THOUSANDS OF YEARS OF HUMAN
EXPERIENCE WHICH WAS HEAVILY
INFLUENCED IN THIS COUNTRY BY
ADAMS AND MONTESQUIEU AND
BURKE IN THE GREAT FOUNDERS OF
THE COUNTRY THAT'S THE BATTLE
GOING ON IN THIS COUNTRY THE
DISMANTLING OF AMERICA IS ONE
-┘- AND ITS CULTURE HAS FOUND A
HOME IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WHICH HAS DEVOURED THE MEDIA
AND PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES AND
OUR ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY AND
THE REST OF US TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT A FANTASTIC AND TREATISES
WE ARE LOSING ELECTIONS AND
THE MEDIA AND THE POLLSTERS IN
THE CONSULTANT IN THE
REPUBLICAN ESTABLISHMENT ARE
LOOKING FOR EASY ANSWERS.
THE PROBLEM IS THEY ARE THE
PROBLEM.
THEY UNDERSTAND THE DEPTH OF
THE PROBLEM WE FACE TODAY.
THEY DON'T WANT TO ADDRESS IT
AND THEIR IDEA OF SUCCESSFUL
POLITICS